empieza un recorrido dentro de la
cordillera oriental de los andes
colombianos al sur de la ciudad de
bogotá se encuentra el páramo más grande
del mundo el de sumapaz una gran parte
está protegida por el estado este
ecosistema nublado de alta montaña está
ubicado a más de 3000 metros sobre el
nivel del mar y solo se encuentra en
costa rica panamá colombia venezuela
ecuador perú y bolivia
es una de las fuentes de agua más
importantes que alimenta las venas
fluviales de latinoamérica
un lugar muy rico en géneros y especies
de flora y el gran protagonista es el
frailejón
nosotros en colombia tenemos 88 especies
de frailejones y de esas 88 especies
nuestro parque sumapaz tiene 61
como una variable pues de una vez
todo empieza con la diosa ma palina como
los indígenas muiscas llamaban a la
niebla baja desde el cielo y entra en
contacto con la vegetación hasta
convertirse en gotas de agua
hay que tener en cuenta que para esa
época en que habitaban los muiscas este
sector del sumapaz y la parte de las
partes bajas ellos veían el páramo como
un sitio sagrado si ellos venían al
páramo única y exclusivamente a ser
pagamentos oa hacer ceremonias de
agradecimiento en este sector
gota a gota el agua empieza a caer al
suelo en el caso del fraile jor el agua
queda depositada en su cuerpo y el
líquido es liberado subterráneamente
este asombroso proceso natural le da
vida a lagunas ríos quebradas y cascadas
pero esta fuente de recurso hídrico vive
diferentes amenazas una de ellas es la
contaminación de los ríos con los
residuos de químicos utilizados en la
agricultura
sandra es una campesina que vive a pocos
metros del páramo de sumapaz en su casa
tiene varios proyectos ecológicos como
este cultivo orgánico de fresas
esta fresa
albiol es una buena planta porque es que
es resistente a las enfermedades se
riega con la mitad del páramo porque
estamos muy cerquita y tenemos esa
fortuna de hacer
evitar los pesticidas es indispensable
en un lugar que suministra agua pura a
millones de personas
todo el impacto es positivo tanto para
lo que tenemos alrededor porque no
estamos echando químico ni todo lo que
está esparciendo ni al agua ni al aire y
además que lo que va a consumir la
persona que nos compro nosotros mismos
son productos limpios que nos van a
nutrir nos van a contaminar nuestro
cuerpo
otra amenaza para el páramo de sumapaz
es el retamo espinoso una planta
invasora atraída de europa capaz de
desplazar y reemplazar las especies
nativas como el frailejón
david es un ecólogo que trabaja en la
erradicación de este arbusto
se dice que un fraile hong tiene la
capacidad de crecer de un centímetro a
dos centímetros anuales y nos
encontramos con una planta la cual crece
un promedio de 12 centímetros mensuales
entonces ella es muy buena a la hora de
competir por la luz por el sol por la
tierra por lo cual comenzó a desplazar
estas especies junto a gonzalo otro
miembro del laboratorio que investiga
esta planta david trabaja tres veces a
la semana en la extracción del retamo
espinoso
tenemos que sacar la raíz o si no ella
puede tener la posibilidad de volver a
rebrotar y crecer e inclusive crecer con
más fuerza por lo cual este este proceso
es el más importante de todos
el páramo de sumapaz es un santuario de
flora y fauna ha apetecido por los
amantes del senderismo
y hoy estaremos en una de las siete
lagunas muescas o lagunas sagradas era
el famoso chaqué o la caminada por los
cerros del páramo hasta llegar a
guatavita con la firma del acuerdo de
paz en 2016 entre el gobierno y la
antigua guerrilla farc sumapaz dejó de
ser visto como un territorio hostil así
que los visitantes curiosos empezaron a
llegar
cuando se abrió muchas personas
quisieron venir a visitar al páramo y lo
hicieron de una manera desorganizada sin
respetar
digamos a las personas locales esto
deteriorio un poco la confianza
entre el turista y los campesinos
locales
roadtrip colombia es una agencia de
ecoturismo que propone salidas al páramo
de sumapaz las caminatas se realizan por
un antiguo camino real ubicado fuera de
la zona declarada parque nacional
natural sumapaz ya que éste no tiene
vocación eco turística
hay unos riesgos frente al turismo
masivo que vengan las personas que nos
respeten los senderos
que se extraigan se lleven las flores
que dejen sus basuras todos estos son
riesgos que nosotros como agencia
asumimos en cada una de nuestras salidas
por eso siempre incluimos un componente
ambiental
son muchos los retos para esta gran
fábrica de agua el páramo más grande del
mundo también vive bajo la amenaza del
cambio climático y si no se controla la
intervención inconsciente del hombre
dejará secuelas irreparables